Where are you?
Please don't take my children
Open... Open your eyes!
Please don't take my children!
How have you been feeling? Have you been sleeping any better?
- Oh rough. Then again I've never slept well before of this...condition.
Condition?
That's called pregnancy. It's okay to say it out loud.
Some things happen. Can you just please drive ?
Did you see something?
Come inside!
What's going on?
People describe seeing an entity that takes in a form of your worst fear.
-Oh, my God!
-What are you looking at? What did you see?
What is wrong with you? Please, stop it!
We can't stay here.
Every contact we've had with the outside...
Has brought us death.
Your kids they deserve hope.
Every single decision I have made has been for them
They're gone.
Cover your eyes! Hold on!
Listen to me.
We're going on a trip now. It's going to be rough.
Hold on!
If you hear something in the woods, you tell me.
If you hear something in the water, you tell me.
But under no circumstance...
are you allowed to take off your blindfold!
Did you hear that?
The creatures!